LAURENCE MORONEY: Hi,
and welcome to Geocache,
where you can walk your way
through things that you can
do with the Google Maps APIs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Laurence Moroney,
and in this episode,
I'm going to talk about
the geolocation APIs
and how you can use them to
locate devices that may not
have a GPS, such as rapidly
emerging breeds of internet
of things devices, or,
of course, in places
where GPS may not be available
due to tall buildings
or other obstructions.
The geolocation APIs
work by accepting
the addresses and signal
strengths of cell towers
and Wi-Fi access
points near you.
From there, they can calculate
a likely latitude and longitude
for your device using a
process called trilateration.
It works like this.
When you scan for
access points near you,
the APIs in your
operating system
will return the unique
identifier for those access
points, as well as
the signal strength.
So when you have the signal
strength and the frequency
at which the access
point transmits,
there's a formula called
the free-space path loss.
And using it, you can
calculate a rough distance
from that access point.
Now of course, this will
only give you the distance
from the access point.
But if you have
a number of them,
then you can scan
multiple points.
And knowing the distance
that you are from each,
this will allow you to
calculate where an overlap is.
And from there, you can get
an estimate for your location.
The geolocation API has the
coordinates of many access
points and cell towers.
So if you tell it the address
of the points near you
and their signal
strength, then it
can use this data to
calculate your likely position
using this technique.
So let's take a look
at how you do this.
The easiest way is to scan
for Wi-Fi signals near you.
Most operating systems
support this natively.
In Linux, the command
is iw dev wlan0 scan.
Or on Android, you'd
use a Wi-Fi manager
that you can get from the
system and set its scan results
to a list of scan result types.
You can then access data
about signal strength
and the identifier of the
access points from there.
Once you have the
data, you structure it
into a JSON file like this,
listing the access points
you've seen, their
signal strength,
signal to noise
ratio if available,
and then you simply call
the geolocation API,
passing at this data
and your API key.
Here's how that would look
like with a curl command.
If you're not familiar with
the concept of an API key
or how to get one, you can
see so in the documentation
at this link.
Now once you pass this
to the geolocation API,
you'll get a return value
containing a latitude,
longitude, and estimation.
And the estimation
is the rough distance
that you are from that latitude
and longitude in meters.
This is because it's calculating
your location by overlapping
distances using
trilateration, giving you
a circle that looks like this.
The accuracy value is the
radius of that circle.
And that's how you geolocate
using Wi-Fi or cell towers.
This will work in indoor
scenarios, or those
where you may not see the
GPS satellites-- for example,
in cities with tall buildings.
Particularly exciting
is the facility
to geolocate internet of things
devices such as this one,
a tiny computer the
size of a stick of gum
that has built in Wi-Fi.
Or this one, a robot
built on a Raspberry Pi
device that geolocates
by sensing Wi-Fi access
points around it.
A great complementary
API is the Roads API,
where if you aren't pinpointed
but you know that the device is
moving along a road, you can
snap the readings to the road.
Here's an example of where
I took a drive with a robot
in my car.
The gray line links where
the readings were taken,
and geolocation gave me
a latitude, longitude,
and estimation.
I passed these to the
Roads API, and then I
got the blue line showing that
I followed that specific road.
That's the geolocation API.
You can learn more at this link,
and if you have any questions,
please leave them in
the comments below.
Don't forget to hit
that subscribe button
to see more Geocasts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]